e tu carissima Cosa fai a capodanno Ah
montagna Beh un classico Guarda a me la
montagna piace eh ma a capodanno
preferisco andare verso mete più
esotiche più calde Sì gli anni passati
hai fatto Seychelles by messico-linesia
Sì quindi volevo rimanere diciamo su
quel livello amo ma a capodanno cosa
facciamo Eh no non voglio che tu prima
io a te Ah cioè ci stavo pensando però
non è che ho tante idee no E poi sta
cosa del Capodanno No ma non ti mette un
po' di ansia Cioè tutta questa
aspettativa Cioè alla fine la serata
come l'altra no Sì ma ti ricordi due
anni fa quando sono andata a Prata Miss
il freddo coppa dito poi ho pagato un
sacco di soldi la discoteca io andavo
dairasca mi divertivo di più carissima
Allora siete pronti per dire dove andate
di bello la curva wow wow adoro Adoro la
montagna comunque ha sempre il suo
fascino No no Noi abbiamo deciso di
andare alle Maldive Sì torniamo per la
sesta volta
massaggi rilassanti al giorno hai capito
se no partiamo il 26 e poi siamo fino al
15 gennaio Eh le vacanze ci vanno bene
non si fanno o no e niente andiamo ha
guardato un attimo i voli mia questi
sono matti eh Cioè praticamente dico
stare più a dare ad Amsterdam che andare
a New York Ma te laggiù ma tipo non lo
so Ho detto provare a vedere a Catania
Quanto costa 1000 €1000 io ma con €1000
mi faccio il giro del mondo in 80 giorni
Mmm Infatti guarda io ti dico tagliamo
la testa al toro ce ne stiamo qua
tranquille cioè Tranquilla Si fa per
dire cioè andiamo a cena con gli altri e
poi ci andiamo a spaccare in discoteca
Fidati che ci divertiamo un botta Ma
perché l'importante capitano Non è dove
sei È con chi sa ha capito la compagnia
che fa caro Ho bisogno di un tuo
consiglio per stasera ehm tubino con
biglietto è un po' più esoso un po' più
sbarazzino e classico tubino nero
Passepartout oppure un qualcosa di più
più esotico un po' più sbarazzino vista
la location Hai proprio ragione Carlo il
tubino nero è un Passepartout è un
Evergreen insormontabile tresoli avevamo
Consigliami che siamo in ritardo allora
tubino nero che però cioè mi sembra
veramente troppo banale
questo di paglietta argentate che però
mi fa troppo capodanno ci ho capito
saranno tutte cose
se no se no proprio Top of the Pops
tubino zebrato Ah no o no vero cioè alla
fine Capodanno lo dice pure la parola
Una volta all'anno cioè capito Ti devi
fare riconoscere Ti devi distinguere che
poi che tu sia le Maldive a Busto
Arsizio diciamo uscire la verità il
Capodanno È sempre una cazzona non
metterlo su così tormentoni anni 80
queste musiche martellanti proprio
Demodè cioè fanno vedere mal di testa o
no no no non lo voglio fare il trenino
perché cioè No I don't want to the
little Train Thank you caro perché non
ci ritroviamo nel nostro banggood e
facciamo il Brindisi a tu per tutti
stasera no Ma che musica c'è Oh vai da
dj amo e digli di metterti Bad Bunny Sì
la tua Noccio quello che fa sì dimmi
pure punto e spacca Oh ma quanti
carissima Buon anno Guarda io sono qui
nel mezzo dell'Oceano Indiano che
sorseggio il mio cocktail ho detto ma
facciamo gli auguri alla Silvana Eh come
stai tu no ma io guarda mi sto
divertendo tantissimo Ieri sono stata
questo cenone super chic sulla spiaggia
c'era che la musica veramente raffinata
mica quelle porcherie di curva eh eh
altri livelli ma dormo Ma quanto ci
siamo divertite Ah ne Io mi sono ripreso
ora Che ore sono 1009 di sera ma alla
fine quanti ne abbiamo bevuti cosa Ma
sei serio Comunque ha proprio vero cioè
se ci pensi Eh con la tua Basta con la
musica giusta reggaeton sa di Bad bunny
anche Torino provincia poi ti sembra
Dubai Oh
Diciamo dopo perché devo andare un
attimo